hello reject nation it's Greg Alba here
and I'm John Humphrey we're gonna watch
the trailer today for a film called
dismiss one of our reward tiers on
patreon is whatever video you request we
must definitely do for certain pledge
tiers and today's Andrew Terpening he
specifically sent that over to us let's
check this out do it well he was after a
lot of sweet life sweet life making or
is this a Jesse Eisenberg
[Music]
a juicer b-plus yeah it's good work
where did you get your degree
I'm sorry where did you go to college
has never been in trouble before sure
blood he's really playing up to Eve over
with this kid did he break it to it what
is going on there's a baby
chose that girl free who why are the
eyes that way dylan sprouse still in
Sprouse indeed we live in a horror movie
sweet life in a horror movie
sweet his brothers do aids you want his
brothers is standard his brothers
brothers his stuntman jump in there cold
why I gotta say I don't know I mean he
looks alright in this he's probably the
the best looking thing about this
trailer I think there are times where he
looks very engaging looks like he's
doing a pretty good job we're in a day
and age now where Disney actors are
playing serial killers you got that one
guy in that Dahmer film Zac Efron is
playing Ted Bundy dylan sprouse is
playing a jesse eisenberg meets the
Caprio meets a Good Will Hunting okay I
like the concept of like evil Good Will
Hunting has a lot of faith in this
student but and he's super smart though
he's kind of psychotic and that's why
yeah I feel like this movie could easily
be really intense and in order to do
that I don't have to be sort of subtle
about things and have to be sort of
character movie or it could be very
silly and cheesy by the end of it I
think the last half is gonna be very
plot heavy and breaking into homes and
zooms like killer threat right here it's
like I start out intrigue yes yes just
start off like how would an interesting
story about a student I keep saying
Jesse Eisenberg because I'm thinking of
his portrayal that he had in that
Facebook movie that that's the what no
it's called that Facebook that dad
Facebook
I feel like first half might be like oh
maybe it's a character movie I like the
idea of a teacher who really wants to
teach and help yeah and a student who
really wants to be the best student how
did he get this but then it becomes like
creepy psychotic movie halfway through I
feel like that's what the movies gonna
be I have a strong sense that the first
half I will find exceptionally more
engaging in the last or or I will be
bored as [ __ ] through the first half be
very engaging against hope lot every one
of those two outcomes is gonna happen I
I don't feel like it'll have a good
balance of managing cool plot thriller
killing people pushing girl white
breaking into / I mean breaking into the
teacher's home it's just a little
ridiculous to me it is and the only
reason I don't know I give that trope is
sort of case-by-case thing we're like us
you know intriguing somewhat disturbed
character is breaking into some place
they happen sometimes that's really
cheesy do you see kid in high school you
know I could see that I could see it
happening and sometimes his performance
looks like he's amping up serial killer
personality and then other times he
seems very believable and engaging I
feel like overall will probably do a
really good job I think when you have a
certain image as a certain type of
personality a certain type of actor
you're really gonna give it your all to
make sure you're not laughed at when you
do a performance like this so I have
faith you do a really good job I could
see why interpreting requested this
video because it's based on how Andrew
Terpening is in my mind this guy who can
just read like three books a day is
super-smart knows a lot about everything
knows how to use guns too and he's very
engaging in calm his intellect is
extremely high I could see that this is
probably what Andrew Terpening had to go
through in high school with a very
specific teacher he had where'd you
graduate from I could see him saying
that I could see him saying I'm excited
to see the interpreting biopic then yeah
so my thanks for the stream west Andrew
and thank you for being a lot more
children dylan sprouse is really he's
not hey guys you can subscribe to the
real rejects please click that
notification bell followed at John
Humphrey and I on social media and also
false and Stardust app and really using
that app a hell of a lot it's a fun app
fun app fun app it is and I also tell
you guys about it it really is part of
the reject community now do it